daniel
mateo said nfts and bitcoins are
as the global reserve currency well
before we go into the global reserve
currency
why don't we talk about what ray dalio
said about bitcoin
being outlawed here's what ray dalio had
to say
about bitcoins being outlawed the
founder of the founder of the 150
billion dollar hedge fund bridgewater
associate the world's largest
made a case that there's a good
probability bitcoin could be outlawed
similar to when the u.s government made
it illegal to
privately own gold as dalia points out
in his upcoming book the changing world
order the gold
reserve act of 1934 made it illegal for
individuals to own gold because
government leaders didn't want to
compete
they don't want gold to compete with
money and credit as a storehold of
wealth
something similar would happen with
bitcoin which has searched against a
backdrop of a high level of debt
low interest rates a lot of liquidity
and stimulus and investors seeking
alternative to bonds and currencies
every country here's what he says every
country
treasury treasures it's monopoly on
controlling the supply and demand
very powerful statement i want to read
that again every country
treasures its monopoly on controlling
the supply and demand sure they don't
want other monies to be operating or
competing
because things can get out of control so
i think
that it would be very likely that you
will have it under a certain set of
circumstances
outlawed the way gold was outlawed
thoughts max apollo well gold was
outlawed with 1933
and uh for in terms of holding
possession of actual physical gold
and then uh was a gerald ford 1974 that
said okay can have it back it
they repealed it is this potentially
something that
bitcoin can be outlawed temporarily for
that
30-40 year process until the government
can figure out what type of
role that bitcoin can play in their
economy i've always said this from the
beginning my position
in the beginning bitcoin sounds cool it
sounds very good but there's a
difference in
in my investing world of intrinsic value
and imputed value
intrinsic value there's an actual asset
that's actually generating
value behind the company imputed value
is what you think it's worth
for me as an investor and and me not
coming from any money
uh driving a bus as a kid and now in
outstanding make money doesn't mean i'm
frivolous with money just throw money at
things
for me it's hard for me to personally
bank on again i won't put my retirement
savings here money that you know needs
to be there
into something that you know again i'm
not giving financial advice
but uh i uh uh i'm saying that uh for
something that is imputed it's kind of
hard to see
the government saying we're gonna
release control
of the number one way to control
american citizens into something
that's uh decentralized it's it's only
one government regulation away
from from bitcoin being outlawed and the
opportunity being stripped away from it
temporarily curious if you're watching
this if you're watching this comment
below do you think
ray dalio is right and there's going to
be some kind of a
you know a bitcoin being outlawed or
controlled by the government tom what
are your thoughts
well i think ray's not trying to make a
controversy here i think he's really
looking at a historical case study
because the governments they control the
interest rates they control the money
supply
m1 m2 and they're out there want to
have the knobs of the economy and they
don't want a secondary
you know currency or value under there
that's why the whole thing happened from
the gold reserve act in 1934.
so i i don't think ray is trying to be
controversial but i i think that the
governments with the fiat currencies and
fiat currency
meaning currencies that are not backed
up by gold or silver they're just
you know the you know the the implied
trading value at that
at that moment as compared to other
currencies they don't want to they don't
want to lose that because they lose
control of the actual
you know economy itself and their
secondary economies there is a case
study on this and it is russia
and the joke during the reagan
administration with russia
is like hey russia can come to the
monetary
trading system once they have a currency
of defined value that can be traded
against other currencies
and remember the ruble was a joke at the
time remember that
and people said what are you talking
about they do have a currency that
trades against other currencies
it says it's green it's got pictures of
u.s presidents on it
and so the joke was that it was u.s
currency was the hard currency in russia
that the russians would actively
conduct commerce on and that flipped out
you know the russian government
so the government's and there's there's
your case study there forget about
communism forget about things but the
russian government didn't want the u.s
dollar to be
you know this underground currency and
they put a lot of steps in try to
control that and it failed but the
government's don't want to give up that
control man
so so go ahead pewdie what do you think
i mean dalio's got a vested interest to
outlaw bitcoin
i mean he's a fiat currency guy he he is
a fiat currency guy but that's my
question for you about bitcoin okay kyle
i want you to think about this as well
from a young standpoint on what you
would say about this
so what is more necessary
and and beneficial selfishly for the
government so think like a politician
think you are biden think you are janet
yellen
who janet yellen's been one of the
biggest proponents of trying to control
bitcoin she's not a bitcoin person she's
not necessarily a pro bitcoin person
right
taking elizabeth warren is elizabeth
warren pro bitcoin
i don't know she's a regulation she's a
regulation person right if you look at a
a biden a elizabeth warren a bernie
sanders
here's what's the weirdest things that's
happened when i talked to people the guy
that sold that nft can you pull up nft
underways uh no every days he just did a
nice one of elon musk yesterday by the
way i don't know if you saw that on a
pretty sick one he did yesterday of uh
so so he sold this for 69 million
dollars
i asked the question in the interview i
asked the question in the interview
uh tom you've heard about this the every
day it's 5 000 days
every day he designed one and then he
put it together very prolific people
people he's phenomenal right so him and
i spoke last week mike
and i asked the question when he did the
uh the auction at christie's
and christie's you know christie's
auction house they do bigger things they
do
artwork they do stuff that's physical
he said there were 33 bidders active
bidders
the last hour of the item it's like at
14 million ended up selling for
69 million i asked the question i said
14 million 33 bidders he said yeah
i said out of those 33 bidders how many
of them are bitcoin
how many of them are bitcoin
millionaires he said all of them they're
all bitcoin
crypto cryptocurrency people so which
means what
every once in a while you know
something comes in where most people
don't take advantage of it
okay we're an average regular joe
who is a little bit you know different
weird people call them crazy people call
them out of the ordinary
ends up buying into it and they put a
thousand dollars in bitcoin when it was
nothing
a quarter a dollar two bucks ten bucks
thirty bucks whatever it is
they put ten thousand dollars into it
now they're millionaires
now they have money some of them have
real money
some of them have a few hundred million
dollars a few of them are billionaire
crypto
billionaires that are out there right
okay
what happens when people are popping out
being billionaires and millionaires
in an industry that not many people
looked at and trusted and there was a
community that was doing
i don't know if there's gonna maybe
there's gonna be some stuff that's going
on that's shady
now they have that money okay so how
much money was being made selling
cocaine
years ago and i'm not making a
comparison the only reason i'm saying
this i'm going to a place with this
how much money is cocaine per year how
much money is
pot per year how big of a business is it
how much money was
alcohol when bootleggers used to make
money behind how much money is it right
is the government more concerned about
control and the worry of currency
manipulation with bitcoin
or is the government more concerned
about collecting
taxes because if you do over regulate
crypto or bitcoin or any of that then
where do you collect the taxes from all
these people that are making billions of
dollars that's revenue going back to the
government
so what's more important to the us
government the control of the currency
to not be able to manipulate our current
fiat currency
or the ability to collect more taxes and
add a tax to it so again let me let me
go a little deeper so this makes sense
to you
so maybe there is no regulation but
maybe there's a bitcoin tax
maybe they're saying we're not going to
regulate it but we're going to add a 15
like you know the same thing they said
the we tax in
new york 13 9 goes to the state 4 goes
to the localities
what if there is a tax on bitcoin rather
than a regulation
is the government thinking revenue or is
the government thinking control
what are your thoughts i think control
is taxation i think if you're going to
control it because because you want to
tax it and then
if you can tax it you can find a way to
manipulate i think it's both pbd
great point you know when russell okan
the nfl players had paid
half of my 30 million dollar in bid
selling bitcoin i mean
so how do you tax now half of a salary
with the other half of the sale it's
easy 40
whop to you know just chop right off to
the to the income taxes
but the other half of his salary went
from 6.5 to 8.5 10.
you can't tax it because it's it's
bitcoin so i think it's both pvd
tom i i i think the conservative side of
government
wants uh reasonable controls
and i think the highly liberal side of
government wants to tax everything
with controls so i think it's a little
bit of both and i think the
you know the central banks and the money
policy people
they want the control back because they
control the world's you know financial
statements
if you're if you and i you've been in
the world of dealing with investors for
a long time
right an investor if the if you
represent an investor and he brings in
the money okay
what are some ways investors control the
entrepreneur
what are some ways if you were to tell
us i know it i'm just hearing from you
so the audience can
what are some ways the investor says
i'll give you this 5 million
i'll give you this 50 million but these
are the controls what are some ways
the investor controls the entrepreneur
the most common thing that people find
with venture investment or private
equity investment is what's called the
preferred position they have what's
called preferred stock
so they get to approve every transaction
over x
and then there's the operating committee
you have you have your boards and they
get a couple board seats so now they got
a certain number of boards so they put
these control that in exchange for my
money
i get these controls because you're a
nice entrepreneur i want to make a buck
on you we all want to make a buck on
this
but we're going to be on your board
controlling these things
and then you can't spend or do things
beyond a certain limit
here or bad things happen and so they
they put controls around their money
and how many controls are there like let
me let me
maybe you're not going as deep as it can
be so one is preferred
the other one is voting control correct
the other one is how much money you can
pay for yourself for salary
sure the other one is how much money you
can spend in one transaction so if
you're gonna do anything anything that
you're gonna spend over fifty thousand
dollars you need our approval a hundred
thousand dollars half a million dollars
a million dollars whatever
how much uh the profit money is a bonus
for executives versus a dividend
back to them to everybody that they
participate in there is so many
different ways that they create controls
right
correct here's a question for you
historically what are some ways
the u.s government can impose controls
on bitcoin taxation being one of them
what are other
creative ways that a janet yellen or a
biden
administration can create controls on
bitcoin and cryptocurrency
wow you're spooked yeah the guy who's
wikipedia
so so so all i'm asking is there are so
many creative ways
what is the way what are they going to
do to create controls
you know attacks being one of them
regulation being another one
you know uh uh how much a
a like you know how um remember when the
gme the gamestop stock went up and then
all of a sudden they said what no more
activity no more activity is there a
lid to be put on it on how much it can
go can they price it themselves
you know one controller is coming and
saying hey gold is worth what was the
dollar amount back in 1934 whether it
was the goals were 30 to 29
34 you remember what the number was 36
maybe
some number like that where they said
here they dictate
what it's worth so can what if they come
out and they say
we're gonna regulate you say bitcoins
worth fifty thousand dollars per
we're gonna put a number on it bitcoin
is worth ten thousand dollars per
like i'm not saying that's what they're
gonna do all i'm asking is
you have to anticipate that regulators
think very differently than freedom
libertarian leave me alone entrepreneurs
innovators so
we have the sec and the market controls
right okay and the sec influences used
to be
the amex used to be chicago board of
options you had all these markets out
there where you could buy and sell
stuff whether it's fruit and livestock
futures or
a share of stock or an option on stock
and the sec has got things in there
about
volatility and what's called the circuit
breakers if the circuit breakers trip
they suspend trading on things
so they can put tight controls in there
that are deemed to
protect the investor robin hood remember
limited how many you could trade a
certain day
sec could step in and do simple things
like that there's a lot of ways that
they could control
the momentum the amount and go back to
the uh
it's not even 100 years ago the federal
reserve act 1934 of how much you can own
i just thought about something the
easiest way to to control and manipulate
it is to increase if you want to pay for
something we can hear you if they want
to pay for something in cash or credit
cards at this price but if they want
paying bitcoin is this price
right yeah the other part is like look
what happened with the industry you and
i are part of right
you got a joseph kennedy who gets
recruited by a roosevelt to come in and
try to figure out the stock market
manipulation and
joseph kennedy calls a meeting
apparently that says hey everybody needs
to come to new york who's selling stocks
and people didn't show up and it's like
wait a minute you better listen to me
and show up they didn't show up so he
says you know what
the only way you can sell stocks moving
forward is you have to pass a license
called a series 7
then everybody ended up showing up they
said the only way you can sell it you
have to
fingerprint because back then there were
caches being handled so they came and do
a finger we're doing fingerprinting till
today we don't even touch cash we don't
even know why we're doing fingerprinting
till today right
so there's an element of licensing
there's an element of
you know those are the things like how
all of they're pretty creative when they
come out with regulation kai do you have
something in mind you want to share with
us yeah no so i think
i think the biggest thing for them also
now that uh essentially because
bitcoin you keep in a wallet right that
wallet essentially the government really
doesn't have access to they don't know
how much is in there
depending on how much you've earned if
you buy in low
you sell high kind of this that and the
others i think a big a big part of it
is that that money can sit in the wallet
and you're not paying any capital gains
or anything of that kind
uh so now that say tesla is allowing you
to buy a bitcoin right
or buy it yeah with bitcoin i think
that's the only place where
government realistically can then go in
and take a piece of the pie
because now they can see oh you have
that you're trading that value
so then they have to come in with some
sort of tax there because if not
the bitcoin can just sit in a wallet and
that money can store that money can stay
there it can grow
yadda yadda yadda or the other way is
when you then
put that money from you the bitcoin into
your bank then it's kind of like oh
suddenly you have 40 million here what's
going on mr xyz
um so for regulation or just purposes of
taxes
i think that they're gonna have to find
a way to tax spending money with bitcoin
on buying something
in that transaction you have to find a
way to kind of get a piece of the pie
there
i remember when uh you're right kai i
remember when there's a point in time
you can buy something on amazon or ebay
without having paid tax on it
there's no there's no tax on it now
that's right now that's right
so this is just another evolution can
they stop bitcoin i don't think they can
but they can find a way to
tax it yeah well there is also that you
long ago
you could commit several wire
transactions and you could effectively
obfuscate what you were doing with money
and then the federal government said it
okay to control it they forced the banks
to be the reporting agency and be
not really the cop of the reporting
agency so what's the limit
on a wire transaction now where the bank
has to turn in your social security
number and the wire transaction
ten grand right a deposit of ten
thousand dollars in a bank the banks
have to report it correct
so now who's not so now the government's
got the okay in exchange for fdic
insurance
you have to and all these other benefits
of connecting the money supply and the
overnight borrowing rate for all the
banks
now you have to tell us every time
there's a transaction of over two ten
thousand dollars
good point so now they're collecting all
the information so they can come back to
you on an audit and say matt you had all
these wires going back and forth you can
no longer hide where your money's coming
going from
was this income or is a savings to check
in what was going on here
and they they know it so there's a lot
of other controls that go in there
that was one of the first we talk about
the government having too much data on
us and things like this
that was a data gold mine for the irs
auditors now they had the banks
recording and reporting every ten
thousand dollars
so banks would have fdi say the bank was
to go in the default the banks have fdic
if uh if you know a brokerage went you
know went to default you have the sipc
what would it be for crypto
would be for bitcoin there is none well
there wasn't those until they needed
them wasn't it correct until people
started losing a lot of money that
there it is there's a protection so so
you're saying if
all of a sudden a lot of people lose
money and there's a dramatic drop
off then we may have an sipc type of
thing set up correct
got it interesting that's the regulation
to protect the consumers
there'll be a crisis and government will
say never let a good crisis go to waste
and in the name of protecting us there
will be regulations and systems put in
place
we got homeland security protecting us
as we go on airplanes
now that didn't exist right but we had a
crisis and
now we have a new government agency as
ronald reagan said
there's never anything so permanent as a
temporary government program
for seat belts and stop signs the stop
lights came from because somebody got
into a
gun to erect cost people their lives
okay crypto right now is at 53 000
right crypto right now is that fifty
three thousand dollars what's more
likely crypto going to a million or
crypto going to ten thousand
good one
i'm the i'm the optimist i'm going i'm
going to a million
million you you wait a minute you think
ten thousand so could it come back to 10
000
on a sell spike a spike of selling
momentum that drives the price down sure
it could
but the limited supply of crypto is like
limited supply
of real estate in malibu the way that
works
that limited supply ensures scarcity so
i think there is actually
yeah could it touch 10 grand on a
trading blip we had so many people
trading on a certain day
sure but i think long term it's more
likely that it continues to trend to a
million so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye